[Music]
hello everyone welcome to my second
lecture of evening play with play like
the pros June just you know so last time
last week I went over a game of Karass
this time I decided to go over a
slightly more recent game actually
played this past week between the world
champion Magnus Carlsen and Guin Jones a
very strong English grandmaster this was
played in the Tata Steel tournament
which is actually still going on I'd
recommend if you haven't tuned into it
to keep going to tune into it now it's
very interesting tournament currently I
believe Magnus is tied with the lead for
the lead with Geary and momager so it
should be an interesting end to the
tournament but this game almost sent
Magnus's tournament completely off the
rails and the reason why is very simple
so part of playing like a pro is
obviously doing lots of good things but
in this case he basically just blundered
a piece the world champion blundered a
piece that may come as a surprise to
some of you but the fact is that
everyone does this once in a while is
the world champion gonna blunder fewer
pieces than say you know an amateur
player at the club almost for sure
it's very rare the world champion will
make like a huge blunder like this or
for any Grand Master but it does happen
but what separates GM's and especially
the world champion from you know lower
rated players is not just that they
blunder less but how they react to
blunders I told you to be blundered a
piece in this game which he did he also
won it against an elite player this is
not a fish so the fact that he could do
this okay obviously his opponent has to
help them out a little bit but it means
that the way he responded to the blunder
was very instructive and that's kind of
more what I want to go over I don't want
to teach you guys how to blunder like
the pros that's another class but I want
to teach you how to recover from Blonde
that you make because you will blunder
hate to spoil any hopes you had of never
blundering but all of us do it so let's
continue to the game efore c5 Knight f3
d6 so Jones really likes the dragon
Carlsen said he barely prepared for the
dragon I find that a little hard to
believe considering this is Jones a
specialty and you you know usually I
find that especially if people are
facing like a world champion or some
elite player they don't normally play
they actually saved their best openings
for them they save the ones they're most
comfortable with so as the dragon or
risky opening of course it is but he
wants to test it against the world
champion why not
so Bishop e3 Bishop g7 f3 this is all
book moves 96 Queen d2 castles castles
Bishop c4 of course is the other line
there are lines also where black tries
to play with early g4 which are a little
different and black plays d5 which is
the main move here so there are lots of
moves
he takes d5 is the main line Black's
been kind of doing okay there actually
as of late King b1 is a move but Carlsen
chooses another line again not one of
the more common lines but definitely
possible the Queen e1 so black plays e5
which is the main a choice here I take
c6 B takes c6 takes here Knight takes
Bishop c4 which is kind of what people
are doing these days
I don't know focus too much on the
opening which is why I'm going a little
quickly but basically black has a lot of
piece play blacks Bishop is hoping to
get open blocks trying to attack but
black also has a slight problem with
this piece in the center and the
question is whether that piece becomes
attackable or not black plays Bishop e6
King bee 1 which again is kind of what
people are doing just slight improvement
to the king getting off this diagonal
for later
and here Jones had played this position
three previous times and you'll find
this is often the case when there's a
very very strong player and Jones is
near I'd say 26 50 or so who plays an
opening that's slightly offbeat you'll
find that at some point you get to half
the games left are their games and
that's the way Jones is with the dragon
he plays the dragon a lot he knows it
extremely well
so some advice I would have is if you're
gonna take on someone like this it's
obviously not everyone plays 26 50s
every day but if you play a very strong
player who has a pet line there's
nothing wrong with going into it but you
have to realize they're gonna be
prepared to the teeth if you play a
risky line like the dragon and that's
all you play you have to know it really
really well believe it or not I've
actually played Jones this was in I
believe it was the world youth under 18
huh not the one I play drama Gareth no
that was a painful game thanks for
reminding me no is the one it was the
one the year before I believe and or no
is the year after actually and I played
Jones and it was a dragon and I thought
I had a good position and he ended up
just crushing me so I know from
experience obviously a long long time
ago we were both quite a bit weaker but
he knows his dragon and one of the
things again you're gonna take someone
on in this you better be well prepared
and also realise they may not just play
what they play one of the things you'll
notice is when say like an amateur
player plays one opening and only that
opening they tend to be very predictable
they'll play the exact same mover or
every time so if you prepare a specific
line for them they're gonna have a
problem and sometimes you can actually
beat them the what very very strong
players will do is they'll vary it up a
little bit he may play the dragon and
only the dragon but he'll play a
slightly different line he'll mix it up
so in this game for sure he had his eyes
Khanna
he was probably suspicious Carlson
doesn't normally play into this this
isn't quite his thing
so Jones and almost every previous game
played rook be it I think in three
previous games he played here he played
with PA in this game he threw Ricky ate
at him and this was an excellent
decision because Carlsen already was not
prepared for this move at the very least
he confused his preparation so 94 which
of course is very natural but the main
idea of Ricky eight by the way is that
it's not as active as rook b8 but there
are lines when white actually can take
this hanging pawn which is kind of funny
in any case 94 was played black played a
5 here Queen c7 I think is actually what
most people play so it's possible that
Jones played rook e8 just trying to
avoid Magnus's prep and that he himself
wasn't fully prepared in this line I'd
say it's unlikely someone like Jones is
gonna know this line really well but in
any case he played f5 which is not some
terrible move magnets played in a g5
Bishop c8 which is kind of the common
pattern here and in this position though
Magnus really revealed that he was kind
of bluffing a little in the opening
because in this position he I don't know
how much time he spent I wasn't
following his live but he played an
atrocious move I'm not gonna have you
guys find the atrocious move but I will
have you find a good move here it's
White's turn so we'll start with that
you can but you're fixing my pawns and
sacking the exchange so I would say if
you do this you better have a very
specific idea
look at these ponds we I know we already
did the pond lecture but look at those
guys oh my goodness they're scary I
would be terrified here not that my
tariffs me being terrified should ever
make you play a move or make you not
play a move but I would be I would be
yeah I wouldn't do this remember you
need a follow up right like it's nice to
sack a piece but you know got to have an
idea behind it but there's a very
important question which you should
always ask yourself in which I hate to
make assumptions I don't think Carlsen
actually asked himself this question
which is does my opponent have a threat
and this and I'm asking you guys does my
opponent have a threat there's black of
a threat black has a very definite
threat here I believe yes f4 so the
question is how do you address this
threat
what should white play yeah h4 is a nice
move in just the normal idea in these
types of positions you not only guard
your knight but you're starting your
attack right the only thing is after h6
you don't really want to have to move
your knight back but luckily you have a
very convenient square for this name
yeah and you can say haha pin and again
life goes on black can play Bishop back
to e6 life continues Bishop b3 I think
is a kind of a clever move because
remember this guy is still pinned by the
rock right and again I'm not exactly
sure what's happening here but White's
doing quite okay let's put it that way
but in the game
Magnus played g4 Jones played f4 well I
can tell you he wasn't he looked happier
than he would have been if he lost but
he was very angry with himself he
basically just said it was just an
outright blunder he just missed that
four so now we come to the next decision
you're Magnus let's celebrate we're
world champion yes so we're whites but
we just blundered a piece so we're not
as happy we'll probably mad at himself
he's probably wishing he could throw
something at the wall but how do you
react what do you do do you just resign
do you find a way to play on do you
throw the dice and just play a random
move how do you react here it's possible
sometimes that's the best way like if
you play normal moves you end up you
know with not much so attack is
obviously what you have to go for but at
the same time I would say that a lot of
people approximate a lot like say they
blunder and then they're like alright
well it should be sort of this it should
be sort of this after you blunder that's
the most important time to
accurate if you play one inaccurate move
and allow your opponent to consolidate
easily that's when you're just gonna
lose without a fight
and guess what if black plays well here
you might lose without a fight anyway
but you want to at least give black a
chance to not win give black a chance to
not do it easily
so 94 is a perfectly rational move the
problem is that after I take your Bishop
say you take me back and I go I have
Bishop e6 easy move keeping my King
secure maybe King h8 next and they even
Bishop back there's no way you're ever
gonna touch me they're not when I have
an extra piece you might get attacked
eventually but not me so what did
magnets do instead which is I wouldn't
say it's much better but it's trickier
it's slightly more accurate that a
little bit more accurate we talked about
how he plays very accurate moves in
equal positions and that's what puts
pressure on people well what put
pressure on black here was he played
accurate moves even though he's lost
even though he's down a piece he's
playing accurate moves so what's the
most accurate move problem is if you
give up the knight and you don't even I
mean the problem here is I mean this is
a pretty big night so let's say here
takes here this is tempting because
Bishop h4 Queen h6 but somehow you can't
really do much there it's kind of
annoying
you can play rook takes Knight but the
problem is now we just simplify and
simplification is not your friend right
that's gonna make things a little bit
harder for you so you're still just down
a piece for a pawn but you're never
gonna attack here right now with these
bishops so this is not the right
approach Bishop h4 is very tempting I
have to admit but he wanted black to
have to take so that it blacks pawns
would be bad so that he'd have something
to play against you want your opponent
to at least have weaknesses if you're
gonna be down material if they have no
weaknesses it's gonna be artur h4
excellent move so black captures
now plays h6 but this is the point now
if black wants to put the bishop on e6
black has to create a weakness black has
to push pawns on the kingside which he
does not want to do so again it seems so
minor but little things like this make a
difference now continue to be accurate
continue to make black find the best
moves what is white play here 94 would
be the normal move but then as we
discussed bishop goes back bishop goes
back what do you have you're just down a
piece and again sometimes that you have
to accept that but he wanted to make
black's life a little bit trickier
so again accuracy is key queenie 4 is
possible the only problem is if i defend
my knight your knight does not have a
retreat then but he does play a similar
move actually after Queen e4 I might be
able to just take your name come to
think of it maybe
yeah if Queenie for I think I can take
this although I have to say I approve of
the fact you're trying to make it
complicated right
problem is you probably take with rook
right but the problem is I think you
simplify a little much
then I take I could still play Bishop e6
there I'm not I don't have to take you
and yeah you can take yeah this is not
good right just not only you're running
out of pieces is the problem it's nice
to attack but you need pieces to attack
so he played a very similar move though
attacking this pawn and what's the
problem now why would he play this move
why is it so important to put the Queen
there
well I don't think the king really wants
to go to fate it would rather go
somewhere else but it's preventing black
from just consolidating remember after
94 black plays Bishop e6 and
consolidates that's kind of the whole
key when you're up material and he's
kind of asking himself what does Jones
want to do when you're up material you
want to consolidate you want to make
your positions solid right because in
the long term if you make your position
solid you're just gonna win you're up
material right once you get your solid
you slowly build you slowly improve but
if your position is a little bit less
stable if your Kings a little weak if
you have some slight problem that can
make your life just that little bit
harder and again he's not I mean he's
not claiming to be winning here but he's
putting that little bit extra pressure
on black so what does black have to play
now most likely
d7 this is d6 you mean e6 the problem
though is that now this bishop hangs so
for example I mean maybe Queen takes
pawn is playable but even if I take you
might have to deal with a move like this
and I'm not saying that this is all that
all that great probably you'll still be
up a piece but it's a little annoying
right you're losing a pawn your getting
pinned up I don't know but I also might
just take this one too so now I'm still
threatening Knight takes c6 on you if
you take this knight then you're opening
up your King as well so for example
maybe maybe now Bishop takes or even
rook takes is maybe possible but you see
how your life's getting complicated
that's what Magnus wants he wants black
to have to make tough choices to have to
be like Oh either I have to allow attack
or in this case he plays Bishop e7 so is
this some awful move of course not
but why did why did he want to make sure
the Bishop went there
right this Bishop is worse here than it
is here right it leaves blacks King more
open it's not there's a pawn in the way
so it seems like such a minor thing like
why would you bother with this well when
you're done a piece you need every
little edge every little chance you get
if you were to allow the black bishop
here wouldn't be some blunder computer
would be like adds a little worse but
from a human standpoint it matters a lot
if you allow your opponent to just get a
nice solid position they're probably
just gonna beat you up a piece right so
he plays a knight back and black plays
rook e6 I'm not a huge fan of rookie six
he's trying to kind of create a sort of
solid thing for his pieces he's trying
to control the d square square I thought
this move was more clear forcing the
Queen away immediately Queen comes out
maybe King g7 if he need to I don't know
but okay rook e6 is not some awful move
white plays h5 and this is where he gets
a little help remember you're down a
piece if you don't get help you're
probably not gonna not gonna hold the
game
what should black do here but you ready
it's possible but I move my queen I
don't think it changes too much here I'm
not threatening to go in two days e6
I do not like any of these moves I can
tell you when I was playing through this
game I I'm not totally sure but probably
I would play this move very quickly yes
keep the position closed if you have an
open King that's where you can get into
trouble you don't have a bishop here if
you had a bishop here it might be
different you could probably allow more
well your bishops out here keep the
Kings side closed do not try to be
tricky do not try to be super tactical
keep things simple yes you go up to f5
square does that five score gonna kill
you
probably not you're up a piece right
next you play Queen b6 maybe it's not
the most accurate move in this case I
think it might be but it doesn't matter
you keep things simple you keep the
Kings side closed and this is I think
the thinking that Jones didn't do I
think that he really wanted to be really
accurate he wanted to like punish in the
most severe way which sometimes is the
right approach but there are times when
you should play simple just be like all
right I'm up material I want to keep the
game not complicated right you want to
keep things simple when you're up g5
keep the position closed so I think that
would have been a much better decision
he played Queen b6 which doesn't look
like an awful move but it actually
allows Carlsen together to get a counter
play immediately and then already he may
not be losing already not so easy
so trading Queens Jones would be
cheering wildly if you take on v68 it
takes you fix your pawns you cover the
c5 square he doesn't care if he has to
give over the palm he'll be like you
know jumping up in his seat if he saw
that
quit anything is possible but even at
the very least maybe I came and played
g5 their mission of our fates also a
move keep in mind
what move did black not play I like your
logic and all of a sudden I don't know
things are messy right forget about the
fact that objectively is now not so easy
let's say black black we're still
completely winning the same as if you
had played g5 would you rather have this
position or the position after g5 if you
were black which one would you rather
have against the world champion not that
it should matter I'm just adding
pressure to your choice
you'd rather have g5 right h6 g5 you'd
rather have the position closed
regardless of whether this is
objectively annoying or whether you can
get by it this is annoying to play you
don't wanna have to do this and when
you're up a piece sometimes you have to
allow complications sometimes you can't
win the simple way and then okay you do
what you have to do but if you're up a
piece for not much counter play for very
little keep it that way
keep the position closed g5 turns out to
be a just an excellent move but after
this it's all of a sudden extremely
messy so there are lots of moves in the
game he took on g5 Queen takes c5 hmm
Queen takes d5 is losing yes how rookie
seven indeed so trading Queens would be
nice
Bishop f8 is kind of my favorite line
because now White has to find a very
nice move to keep pressure but it does
and by pressure I mean counter play I
don't mean like you're better though so
here almost for sure I would take very
quickly because now the Queen's attacked
it takes you just take back with the
pawn for example the Knights attacked
you're in an endgame your bishops are
monsters astrology is good for you right
whereas if you try to grab this Queen
like a greedy person and I hate greedy
people in general but especially greed
chess players Bishop takes rook and now
this pawn this
pawn rook coming to d7 just a mess right
tons of counter play so almost for sure
I would never take that Queen maybe I
would have to calculate it a little bit
just to make sure I have counter play
just to make sure the other lines not
winning but I am very quite sure I would
probably take that bit in any case this
is the move quite a move huh but the
idea is that now black wants to trade
Queens black has to bring your rook into
the game
and with the rooks on g1 and these pawns
here it's gonna be a little
uncomfortable for this King isn't it
gonna get lots of counter place so for
example if takes takes so here
G takes H 5 is what I wanted at first
but after check rook H 5 I don't know
seems like there's lots of counter play
right not to mention if you lose too
many pawns it's gonna be hard to win
just with limited pawns right even if
you are upper piece so it turns out
black actually has a really cool idea
here but it is far from obvious Knight
f4 I'm not sure how that helps you men
you have a hanging rook all the time
which I don't have to take by the way
I can take on g6 I can take on h6 I
think you need this night here I think
you needed protecting yourself a5
doesn't really do a whole lot then it
gives me a free move I can take here I
can take here you don't to give me a
freebie I understand you're trying to
play Bishop a6 and I'm not saying that's
a bad idea
but it's a little slow you need
something a bit faster
bless you the main threat to give you
guys an idea is to take the H pawn
because then I have h7 check as an idea
and I come into g5
if you allow me to play Hg I'm gonna
have pretty nasty pawns so your move
should somehow combat taking on h6 it's
a very tricky idea though kh7 makes
sense but unfortunately I'm not so sure
you've prevented my ideas so for example
I take here
the funny thing is this King you might
end up regretting putting it here you're
kind of putting in the line of fire
tonight see if you take on a stick of
the bishop I have this Fork if you take
otherwise I have this Fork I have this
move too much right it's actually this
move but the key is to realize what the
purpose is at first you're going wait
how does this prevent takes on sticks
but there's a very specific idea king h7
that's true but that means you could
have played King age seven takes fishery
soon I thought there was a there's a
problem in this move let me check
oh I'm starting to see where your
problems might arise Bishop coming to d3
is slightly scary yeah but King up seven
you're letting my age pong go so that
also has its drawbacks oh yeah
the move is g5 so the key is you keep
things blocked you keep see how this
rook now is not doing anything it's all
about the pieces more than the pawns
it's the opposite of my last lecture so
Knight takes d5 rook takes 86 you allow
a discovery which does nothing and this
you have a safety is the key this King
can go to h8 if the knight moves will
check you kind of keep black at bay at
white at bay and believe it or not black
still maybe a little better here
but I would say that the position
practically is still quite unclear not
so easy to do yeah this I would say I
would not be even remotely angry if they
don't find something like this this is
like I would be very happy if I found
this this is very tricky but my point is
more like if you allow g5 like I would
be very unhappy they don't play g5
because that's just a very simple
concept don't make your life complicated
don't do that even though this is a 2650
making this mistake you know this is
keep in mind it's a guy who's like 100
points higher than me or whatever right
he's better than me but I would be very
angry with myself if I made if I didn't
play g5 I would be angry with an 1800
student who didn't play g5 that's how
big a mistake I think that was
whereas now I'd say you have to make the
best of it and these decisions are
difficult these ones now part of the
reason why allowing G if I was so bad is
because now you have to make tough
choices you saw how tough that line was
right how many of you guys think you'd
find Bishop e7 g5 honestly I think my
odds of finding it would be low at the
exag if I'd give myself a fighting
chance 25-30 percent but it's still very
difficult right
hmm for me Oh for you maybe don't doubt
yourself too much but the point is that
it's really tough right but this is the
whole point if you don't keep your life
simple then even if your position is
still good you have to make really tough
choices and that's where people will
mess up that's where the pressure gets
you remember you're playing the world
champion think of the pressure that that
includes right even if you're not even
if you're just playing some guy at the
club who's a hundred points higher than
you 200 points higher than you you make
that one little mistake you give them
the complicated position you force
yourself to make tough choices that's
where things go awry now let's take it
from Carlsen's point of view because
that's what we're focusing on if you're
playing against someone who's up a piece
on you who has a winning position keep
the game messy keep it so that they have
to worry about stuff so that they have
choices to make the more choices you
give them the more likely it is they're
gonna make a wrong one write down two
rooks I'd say that's probably too much
mostly in any case Queen g1 though it's
kind of a cool move huh
in any case black took this pawn and now
white just gets lots of play but the
question is what to do because you can't
really take on g5 now
h6 is possible I might have Bishop
i'faith done though even after h7 check
King h8 I'm not sure your pawns actually
doing much
good look at it so I might play at age I
could play at h8 but then h7 check he g7
them kind of ugly so I'd rather try to
play here do you want to play h7 Yes No
maybe so let's say you play h7 cuz it
looks the most threatening right King h8
yeah well already trading Queens is not
something you want right oh look at this
pawn structure so beautiful
alright now what so as long as I don't
allow Knight f7 I think black is doing
quite well no rook age 6 I think you
just lost keep in mind this is a huge
improvement to my position it looks
silly but even when you're up a piece if
you have a nice pawn structure it makes
winning simpler this is totally true if
you have a messed up pawn structure and
half your pawns are being are weak or
getting attacked it's just hard to win
right it's hard to keep things stable
when your pawn structure is super nice
your pieces all get out notice how all
the squares are covered right you're not
attacking me anymore this pawn is not
going anywhere
so that would be I think not the best
and I'm guessing if anything this was
the idea that Jones Miss Jones probably
thought he could take on g5 and white
didn't have anything here the problem is
that once you take on g5 your Kings
already messed up right your King sides
already open damage is done
so sometimes it's kind of like a dive
bomber once the damage is done you
backtrack so what does he do
he needs to be able to take on g5 right
and start taking stuff he doesn't want
to trade Queens so what does he do and
this was an idea Alex had earlier mm-hmm
yeah just go back damage done mission
accomplished
the bomb was dropped that did its damage
now leave and that's kind of what it is
cuz this like black-white just lost the
pawn but look at this King look at this
King side and already this position is
massively difficult for black I would
say so black played rook b8 and this is
one decision actually I'm not crazy
about Carlson's move for him I think
tonight takes g5 queen d3 and then maybe
b3 next move is simpler keep your queen
in the game keep it kind of nice again
it's not easy but this is maybe it would
be my choice he ended up playing here
instead but I didn't like my Queen so
much now
so yeah in this position black should
have taken again it looks risky to just
put your pawns out here but once G fives
happen and again this is why not playing
g5 I was so harsh on once this happens
your kings already opened you can never
close it right there's no way you can
close the position over here pawn
structure wise Kenya and this is kind of
a key if you can't close the King's side
you kind of have to surrender the fact
okay it's gonna get open I just have to
take stuff
so if takes here Knight takes rook f6 I
don't know I think blacks doing alright
here it's still not an easy position but
you know white still has tons of counter
play but Jones actually justified this
b3 move with his next move he played
Queen to d8 trying to prevent Knight
takes d5 entirely but this move is
a too ambitious so Carlson has a very
strong move now I kind of misled you
with all my anti greed talk earlier I
think that was the problem yeah why not
it's there it's ripe it's ready but more
importantly the Queen now here is kind
of acting as a paralyzing agent right
this rook can't move this Bishop can't
move the Queen can attack directly and
remember this Queen was out of the game
right so why not take upon leave black
with this horrible mess and already
black's decisions are becoming very
tough but can you imagine Jones in this
position he won a piece against the
world champion he knew he was just type
of piece he didn't think the Magnus
acted right so he said you know he
allows one g5 move and then all of a
sudden oh my goodness here they 7 pawn
drops so it's very important if you're
in this situation is black I would say
not only have all of us blundered before
but all of us have and will not convert
well when our opponent has blundered
things will have gone against us things
will become more complicated and it's
just as important in those positions to
keep your calm to not panic to not do
anything insane now here it's already
really tough for black but I would say
that if he had kept his calm instead of
a letting white take on a seven if he
had you know taking on h5 played rook f6
kept the position together maybe he
would have drawn this game maybe he
would have kind of recovered
whereas now his life is very difficult
so I thought he should play rook e7 here
at least keep things okay
threatened rook e8 and I actually
thought that white had kind of a funny
move here which was to play a four the
idea being that if rook a8 Queen moves
Queen a5 no longer threatens anything
but okay
a4 is kind of a tricky move maybe not
the only one the Queen will probably
drop back to our favorite g1 square
again common motif right kind of a funny
move but instead white took here so what
is black sorry black took an h5 so it's
the same thing I suggested it's just one
move too late so what does white do now
why for now there's no rocket threat
nice try don't try to just steal my
ideas I I ask you questions at specific
moments yeah why not
this paw is not going anywhere right
thanks rook g6 so how does he make
progress now
seems like black has you sword about bay
guarding the Jeep on
95 looks like a reasonable move
certainly threatening but unfortunately
it has a very bad flaw to it actually no
it doesn't I'm sorry
93 is flawed as well yeah I did the same
thing it's uh it's been a long day
anyway ah all right
uh yeah 95 actually looks like a
reasonable move to me trying to go after
this bishop he decided to take the pawn
though keep in mind this guy still hangs
right you see why queen takes a seven
was such a nasty move it wasn't just
taking a pawn it was paralyzing the
Queen side it takes takes Queen c8 so
blacks just hanging on for dear life so
show me how show me
you guys can go in for the kill now so
many tempting options he goes for this
one keeps it simple right ninety-six is
a huge threat now this Bishop is not
gonna be happy black plays arcades
so why does he go to b6 by the way is he
just being obnoxious or does he have an
idea and maybe he is being obnoxious
keep that in mind takes on d5 also I
think he wants Queen takes d5 96 or even
96 immediately because this hangs now so
sometimes taking I mean this isn't just
a fancy move it attacks more stuff right
and the fact that the Queen happens to
be hanging turns out not to be relevant
so Queen b6 is very accurate I would say
actually that in this game after he
blundered the piece and this is what's
most impressive about this game after he
blundered the piece I think apart from
that b3 move every single move was most
accurate every single move so to give
you an idea it's that's what separates
like the very top from not the very top
imagine you make a horrible blunder of a
piece but then every single move the
rest of the game is perfect how many of
us can say we could do that well you
guys are more confident than I am but
the point is about the mindset he just
resets he's like okay I blundered a
piece I'm playing a new position now
all right I'm lost but I'm gonna just
keep playing and it's important to have
this kind of almost detached mindset
where you're like okay I blundered a
piece new position and black should have
done the same and probably tried to do
it but didn't do it quite as well where
it's like okay I'm not winning anymore
I'm not just type of piece it's time to
just play and it's easy to get
frustrated be like oh I was so winning
y'all I had this I had that but you know
and I'm sure even Magnus might have been
doing that he's like oh I blundered a
piece I'm such a yeah at the same time
didn't affect his play did it he just
kept playing he kept you know trying to
play accurate moves and almost and I'm
actually very serious almost all these
moves are completely accurate which is
very difficult to do so he played rook a
six this is actually not a bad try he's
trying to at least complicate the game
force white to make tough choices drive
the Queen off that annoying square so
does he take the rook
why not that is the second reason why he
isn't there we go
whoops so much for our easy win and I
don't know I mean he's a strong guy I
don't know if he could recover from two
blunders like this in one game I think
at this point Jones would be able to
beat him keep in mind this is a really
strong player this is a 2650 this is not
a fish that's true I'm gonna look at it
what are you crazy
nah but you're still down a piece
unfortunate anyway Queen C but I thought
he should maybe try Queen f8 just too
fast simplify the game the problem is
that after takes oops oh yeah takes was
not as accurate I remember this now
because if takes the problem you have is
that after Bishop takes you can't win
material directly
you have a nice discovery but you're not
discovering anything worthwhile although
this still looks pretty strong maybe you
can win this Bishop but then you may get
trapped sorry I'm just to show you what
I'm looking at a little bit far afield
but the idea is that this happens but
you're a knight it's kind of embarrassed
Sanne not so easy but White has a very
very nice continuation here
both sigh DF Queen takes Queen possibly
maybe it's nothing he didn't consider
this
so 96 is indeed very strong boats the
idea
well there are only two moves that are
worth looking at here and they're real
kings
so black probably has to take white
takes I would say believe it or not
there's far more of a chant there's far
less of a chance of screwing up to up to
pawns here than there is of screwing up
up a piece and the reason is that the
positions so simplified right but maybe
black should have at least tried this I
don't know black instead played here and
decided to get slaughtered instead
although to be fair to him it was a very
difficult choice
so okay continue show me you guys can do
this good move
threatening Knight f6 that will be very
nasty so he plays King h8 very nice so
again a lot of it's just you know you
bring your pieces into the attack and
the position plays itself keep in mind
it's not just that the position
objectively is bad it's so tough to play
your kings open white's is completely
safe this rooks always hanging you're
threatening Queen h4 Knight f6 so the
rook can't even move and it's just so
difficult to actually just play so he
plays Queen e7 I actually just like
Queen g3 and I feel like you're just
gonna crash through you know it's pretty
bad but he decides to get kind of
technical now he just is like all right
I'll take the rook I'll be down a little
bit less material sometimes people do
this just to make life easy but but I
don't know there are times when you
don't want to take that rook you want to
just keep pressing you want to keep
attacking but this is good enough
he plays Queen h2 and now
so he's putting pressure here but he
also was attacking what mm-hmm so yeah
by blacks should try this but after it
takes black can at least play on here
but again I would say that even though
objectively you know it's lost but maybe
you can play like from a human
standpoint it's so easy to blunder here
if you're black
just cuz all your pieces are loose
everything hangs it's just very
difficult in the game he played here
Queenie six check rook g5 threatening
rook out 593 mean d6 tonight c5 and
finished the game off how
keep in mind you don't have to meet you
just have to make your opponent resign
yeah look it for look for loose pieces
what's loose here
this guy's lose this guy's lose this
guy's lose this guy's lose the skies
loose so all the pieces are loose but
I'd like to be helpful but seriously
what are your temple moves what's loose
tempo move should take care of this one
hmm simple simple don't be fancy what's
hanging pork right King moves takes hear
you're up three pawns with zero counter
play and you still have an attack any GM
is gonna resign here this is not one of
those positions where you play it out
hoping they bump there's no way to not
win this wait here in any case so you
saw how it happened right like he just
blunted a piece out red but kept in
there kept his play so I guess the key
things to remember are don't relate you
have to reset once you blunder you have
to realize you blunder reset take a
whole new view of the position the next
step is be accurate you saw how he
played completely precisely after he
blundered not an easy thing to do for
anyone but the key is be accurate if you
play a couple inaccurate moves it often
is the difference between being a piece
down but being able to fight or being a
piece down and having no play that
you're just gonna lose and be aware when
the game switches around you know when
you're starting to play for the
initiative when you're playing for their
advantage again keep those chances and
again if you're up the piece make sure
you keep things simple that g5 move was
what stood out to me if you played g5
the likelihood of Magnus coming back
very low in my opinion but yeah even the
pros even the very best blunder pieces
sometimes so do not get discouraged if
you do so and hopefully this will
encourage you not to give up in those
games to keep fighting
you
[Applause]
[Music]